I'm Charles Payne I'm Kat timff I'm
Stuart Vonnie and this is the Fox News
Rundown
Wednesday March 29th 2023
I'm Dave Anthony
it's his latest move in his war on
Ukraine
Russian leader Vladimir Putin plans to
put nuclear weapons in nearby Belarus
this is a sort of effort by him to break
the will of the Ukrainian people to
convince them that their resistance is
futile I'm Jessica Rosenthal after young
children were murdered in the latest
mass shooting this one again at a school
the president called again for an
assault weapons ban but what is the
future of new gun laws after a recent
Supreme Court decision these things need
to be clarified they need to be
presented clearly and they need to be
hammered out in a good faith effort like
the encountered and I'm will Kane and
I've got the final word on the Fox News
Rundown
[Music]
Russia's war on Ukraine is now in its
14th month and leader Vladimir Putin has
suffered setbacks and a lot of
casualties depleting Russian forces so
he is once again raising a nuclear red
flag with a plan to move what are called
tactical nuclear weapons into Belarus
his neighbor and Ally that borders
Ukraine these tactical nukes are
disturbing Republican Congressman
Michael McCall chairs the house Foreign
Affairs committee and also told Fox News
Sunday tensions are rising I think this
is saber rattling on the part of Putin
to
basically try to frighten with the
operations going on though Putin claims
just following America's lead that the
U.S already put nuclear weapons in
European countries these are Battlefield
nuclear weapons these are nuclear
weapons designed to change the tempo on
the ground in a conflict so they're not
a strategic threat to the United States
Stephen Hadley is a former National
Security advisor an editor of the recent
book handoff the foreign policy George W
bush passed to Barack Obama but there's
certainly a Potential Threat for to
Ukraine and to our friends and allies in
Europe so it's something to be concerned
about why is Putin doing this this is a
sort of effort by him to break the will
of the Ukrainian people to convince them
that their resistance is futile and
break the will of the Europeans and the
Americans and others including our Asian
friends and allies who are supporting
Ukraine so this is part of his
psychological warfare moving them from
that country Russia to Belarus what what
does he accomplish strategically uh so
Belarus from the beginning has been
supportive of Russian deployments to be
used in the war but Belarus itself has
not committed its own forces in the
effort by Russia against Ukraine uh and
I think Putin is trying to draw Belarus
closer and closer to the conflict and
putting tactical nuclear weapons in
Belarus is one way to do that
if one is used what happens because if
you use it don't wouldn't it affect your
own troops too
it's a question one of the things you
need to be careful about is are your own
troops at risk you know the winds in
that part of the world move of course
from west to east so the risk is that if
Russia were to use a tactical nuclear
weapon The Fallout would fall upon
Russian troops and the Russian troops
he's using in Ukraine are not equipped
to operate in a kind of post-nuclear
environment so he's there's a question
of how he would use them in a way that
would not threaten his own troops and
there's a question of why he would use
them and one of the things he might do
is if this Ukrainian counter-offensive
that has been promised were to really
threaten Russia's position in Ukraine it
is possible that Russia would use a
tactical nuclear weapon perhaps in a
relatively uninhabited place to signal
that we were about to cross a Russian
red line if you will what would the U.S
have to do what would NATO do if there
was a nuclear weapon used in Ukraine
we've stayed out of it militarily other
than providing weapons I think uh the
administration I'm sure is thinking
about how it would respond I think it's
unlikely that they would respond with
their own nuclear capability though of
course there is that tactical nuclear
capability a limited tactical nuclear
capability in Europe I don't think they
would respond in that way I do think
though there would have to be a military
response and I think it would be use of
weapons and potentially even American
aircraft and the like against Russian
forces on the ground in Ukraine to try
to shift the balance in Ukraine's favor
but this is a big move this would cross
a red line that the Biden Administration
has established which is it's fine to
provide military and economic support to
Ukraine but that the Biden
Administration make clear that their
desire is not to have U.S troops or U.S
military forces in Ukraine to battle
Russian troops I think that's a red line
they will try to protect effect but
it'll be stressed if Putin were to use a
tactical nuclear weapon because I think
there would be a lot of pressure to make
a military response and I suspect that
the Ukrainian forces are would not be
sufficient to make the kind of military
response that the administration might
think was required so it would pose a
lot of dilemmas for the Biden
Administration it would be a very
difficult decision for them to make not
to be outdone North Korean leader Kim
Jong-un claims to also have tactical
nuclear weapons seen in the photo State
media released showing him inspecting a
bunch of green Warheads as North Korea
also launches more missile tests angry
over ongoing U.S and South Korean joint
military exercises in a never-ending
nuclear sanctions standoff there is no
evidence that if we stopped our military
exercises with our allies that it would
halt the North Korean nuclear program or
program to develop ballistic missiles so
the question is where are we and what do
we do the strategy so far has been to
enhance deterrence to strengthen our
ties with our allies in the region to
strengthen their defense capabilities to
convince them and to convince North
Korea that our nuclear umbrella over
South Korea and Japan is credible and
that if North Korea were to be so
foolish as to use nuclear weapons
against our allies in the region there
would be an overwhelming U.S response
which would obliterate North Korea the
question is whether the South Koreans
and the Japanese are going to think
that's adequate or whether this is going
to provoke A Renewed discussion in those
countries about whether they need to
develop their own nuclear weapons in
order to deter North Korea and that of
course is a is a question that will then
implicate China because the last thing
China would like is to have South Korea
and Japan have nuclear weapons which
would be justified as is deterring North
Korea but would obviously have a
potential for doing something with
respect to China so this situation is
troubling we have not found over the
course of almost five administrations
how to roll back the North Korean
nuclear program and Kim Jong-un has made
it the centerpiece of his tenure as
leader of North Korea you know you talk
about China
it seems like almost every issue we're
dealing with China is involved in some
way obviously the leader Xi Jinping had
just gone to Russia last week and
there's worry that he might provide
weapons to Russia then you also have
China still trying to work with our
European allies on on a trade agreement
so and they're in Africa investing there
Latin America they're trying to get
involved they're everywhere we turn
there's China
that's exactly right they are have
pretensions now to be a global power
and to be a predominant power on the
global stage as well as of course what
we would call a regional hegemen uh in
uh in Northeast Asia so that is the
China Challenge and we are I think have
been slow to awaken to that challenge I
think the Trump Administration gets a
lot of credit for waking the American
people up to the challenge of China and
I think the Biden Administration is
working on a bipartisan basis to try to
put together a strategy that the
elements of which are already emerging
for dealing with what is going to be a
challenge from China that we're going to
face for the decades ahead now to Israel
and the widespread protests that pretty
much shut the country down Monday
tens of thousands out demonstrating
including many workers who went on
strike angry at Israeli Prime Minister
Benjamin netanyahu's plan to overhaul
the country's Judicial System his
critics fear it'll give Netanyahu and
his ruling party too much control over
courts later that day he relented and
put the plan on holds she is absolute
when there's an opportunity to avoid
Civil War through dialogue I as prime
minister am taking a timeout for
dialogue but will that be enough to calm
things down I think just to defer it is
not enough I think my own View and this
is Israel is a democracy they are going
to have to find their own way out from
under this crisis but my own view is
they need a process of consideration of
the criticisms that have been made of
the existing system it doesn't have a
written Constitution it's rules about
the role of Judiciary somewhat informal
if you will they need day process by
which these objections and concerns of
both sides can be addressed and try to
build over time a consensus as to what
kind of changes are appropriate to
address the Grievances on both sides of
this issue good luck I think that's what
they need that's going to take that's
going to take some time I mean they've
had they had numerous numerous elections
to try to even elect a prime minister
that failed over and over again and now
it's back to Netanyahu it's been very
difficult
it's very difficult but one of the
problems was this issue was not part of
any of those election campaigns
certainly not the last one as I
understand it it was not something that
was on the agenda that Netanyahu put
before the country when he entered into
office so it's come somewhat on the
agenda with surprise and without
preparation and I think that accounts
for the extreme reaction in the streets
and that's why I say you need a much
more deliberative transparent process
where these objections and concerns can
be dealt with and some consensus can be
built in order for a solution if this
crisis is going to be avoided but how
does that affect us I mean it's
political in that country but the Middle
East conflict Israelis versus
Palestinians that seems to be the one
that could grow into something larger
versus the political stuff in Israel or
am I wrong about that
you don't like to see your close friends
and allies debilitated by internal
political Strife similarly no one wants
to see the situation between Israeli
settlers and the Palestinians descend
again to another itifada and terrorism
and loss of life on both sides and there
has been loss of life on both sides
already it's in nobody's interest for
that to build because it will strain
Israel's relations with its own
Palestinian citizens with its
Palestinian Neighbors on the West Bank
and it'll strain its relationship with
the Arab countries in the Middle East
who have entered into these Abraham
Accords where they have recognized the
state of Israel and established
diplomatic relations with Israel this is
a huge breakthrough on behalf of Israeli
security and Israel's position in the
region and it is put at risk if there is
a new and spreading violence between the
Israeli Security Forces Israeli settlers
and Palestinians Stephen Hadley former
National Security adviser editor of
handoff the book that's the foreign
policy of George W bush passed to Barack
Obama thank you again for joining us
delighted thanks for having me foreign
[Music]
this is Will Kane with your Fox News
commentary coming up
this week there was yet another mass
shooting and again this one was at a
school a Christian Elementary School in
Nashville Tennessee three nine-year-old
children were among those killed along
with three adults the suspected shooter
a 28 year old who went to the school
there when they were younger according
to police was killed by law enforcement
police said the school had no officers
present or assigned to it Nashville
police spokesman Don Aaron said of the
shooter we know that she was armed with
at least two assault type rifles and a
handgun President Biden said more needs
to be done to protect schools without
turning them into prisons so I again
call on Congress to pass the assault
woman's man pass it it should not be a
partisan issue it's a common sense issue
we have to act now people say why do I
keep saying this if they're not
happening because I want you to know who
isn't doing it but is it that simple the
Supreme Court's Brewing decision last
year found New York's law that required
a license to carry a concealed weapon in
a public place is unconstitutional the
ruling said gun cases moving forward
need to consider the historical
tradition of firearms right regulation
South Carolina Senator Lindsey Graham
introduced legislation to codify that
Supreme Court decision into law along
with the Heller Decision which affirmed
an individual's right to keep and bear
arms because the second amendment was
designed to allow people to defend
themselves
in dangerous situations
outside their home there's nothing in
the Second Amendment about you can own a
gun in your home and nowhere else but
during a recent Judiciary Committee
hearing Democratic senator Dick Durbin
of Illinois said the Bruin decision has
upended gun cases being heard in courts
around the country now the Supreme Court
has imposed a radical new framework
under judge Thomas's decision with
barely any guidance to apply it plenty
of opportunity for judges to cherry-pick
from history to engage in judicial
activism in the name of originalism so
then what does all of this mean for the
future of gun laws and regulations as
the president calls for an assault
weapons ban going forward regarding
Bruin I think we're in for some
turbulent Road as all of these states
try to figure out how they can
synchronize with the Bruin decision Paul
Morrow is a former NYPD inspector and
attorney it is also though to go to
another piece the political aspect of it
and I think that most pointedly resides
in the president's use of the term
assault weapon because
what are the nuances of this is that
what an assault weapon actually is is
far from a determined fact most people
tend to think of an assault weapon as
being a fully automatic weapon that is a
machine gun you press the trigger and it
fires numerous rounds well AR-15s which
the president is referring to here and
numerous people refer to as an assault
weapon doesn't operate that way you pull
the trigger once it shoots one round
it's not you depress the trigger once
and it continually fires in fact machine
guns are very heavily regulated in this
country so
the idea of quote-unquote banning
assault weapons is a very pointed and
likely effective political talking point
but what does that actually mean because
if you ban AR-15s that is a gun in which
you press the trigger once and it fires
one round you are going to take a large
category of similar weapons with it and
I don't believe that's the cool hunting
rifles and stuff and so I don't believe
that that's the intent of what he's
talking about so these things need to be
clarified they need to be presented
clearly and they need to be hammered out
in a good faith effort likely in
Congress put on your your former NYPD
investigator hat here which obviously
you do multiple times especially when we
speak to you but when the President says
you know we need to do more to protect
schools without turning them into
prisons
let's talk about school security I don't
know how many times you've responded to
a school or if you have but you know I
asked the deputy at my kids school after
the Nashville shooting you know what
would happen if he was getting coffee or
in the restroom and someone shot through
our glass door and you know he said
there are devices in the hallway that
would actually alert 9-1-1 in in that
event do we just need to rely more on
Tech is it time to spend money on
additional security Staffing or Harden
our schools in a different way
I think it is
um and I don't want to take that default
response to the full solution which so
many of us are guilty of I'm just saying
yeah we need more of this we need more
of that and being blind to the cost
right these things can get expensive but
what I would argue with the lesson
embedded in what we know so far from
Nashville is that the defensive approach
the prophylactic approach does work and
so I feel like one of the things that we
could be leveraging our retired police
officers to come in and potentially work
in our schools to harden those places
and just the fact that they're there
will have such a prophylactic effect
that I think that we could potentially
cut down on some of these incidents
wow finally Paul when you hear this
shooter Nashville was being treated for
an emotional health disorder her parents
were aware of her struggles they told
her to sell her guns clearly she hid
some of them I suppose no amount of
money in the world can really force you
to get mentally healthy and that
bipartisan safer communities act signed
last year that includes Millions for
mental health treatment but what do we
do with this other than offer people
help and hope they take it
I know and that's a really really funny
issue because what you're getting into
there is a civil issue right and what
would have had to have happened here
realistically is the parents apparently
were under the impression that she had
divested herself of all of her guns she
had not
um so realistically what would you have
had here the parents would have had a
committer or they would have had to call
the police and have them come to the
house and make sure the fact that she
didn't have the guns and you know you
get into very thorny issues of what if
she didn't live with the parents they
make that call did the police have the
power to go in there New York has some
red flag laws that allow you to do this
kind of stuff
um Brewing may you know throw them into
flux as well look once somebody starts
shooting in a school no matter how good
your response is you've failed and uh I
think that's a lesson of Nashville
because the response here from the
police was quite good yep we have six
people dead so I think a better level of
monitoring standard protocols for
response
hardening a Target as much as possible
and a campaign I think you have to where
you have to say you know look folks and
this is on a nationwide level now
any doubts call it in
and we probably do have to get to the
point where and I know it feels like
people would be sort of turning on each
other but if you have a family member
who has guns and you you know suspect
that there is maybe some mental illness
there make the call because this is not
the first ones of these remember that
kid learns it same thing you know the
mother had this gun cabinet that he had
access to one look at that kid's mug
shot you can see God bless him that he
was uh in real mental distress
and you have to say it was incumbent
upon his mother to make that call and
she didn't but when it comes to the
president's call for an assault weapons
ban that may depend on what side of the
political aisle you're on after the
Supreme Court's Brewing decision came
down the National Shooting Sports
Foundation said it applies a true
reading of what the Bill of Rights tells
us and does provide Clarity on a
fundamental right but Chris Brown
president of the Brady campaign against
gun violence says since then they've
seen judges issue very different rulings
around the country host Bruin there's a
lot of confusion about how to apply this
rather complex standard and a lot of
thought from Advocates like me a lot of
head scratching about how this could
possibly be a workable standard in the
21st century
yeah let's talk a little bit about that
so I I was reading you know one judge in
Delaware said this new test
um to apply thanks to Bruin means a
ghost gun law Banning their
manufacturing possession cannot stand
but a judge in California rejected a
challenge to their ghost gun law the
fifth Circuit Court of Appeals struck
down a law that said you can't have a
gun if you have a domestic violence
restraining order against you so
regardless of how you feel politically
about Firearms this sounds messy what do
you foresee in terms of I guess would
this have to come before the court in in
the form of another case regarding
firearms
yes and I think it will you mentioned
this fifth circuit case and for your
listeners that's a case where it was
recently held that a law that's been in
effect for a while and is quite
important uh judge in the fifth circuit
which is a federal district court said
well actually now I'm looking at that
law and applying the Bruin decision
which has these new factors which
require me to look back in history and
understand whether there was a corollary
to this law in effect in colonial times
and I'm finding that there wasn't and
therefore I'm going to hold a law that
says domestic violence abusers
should have their guns removed I'm going
to hold that as unconstitutional which I
think is not a good standard
Chris what does all of this mean when we
hear the president say hey Congress it's
time for an assault weapons ban we all
remember well not all of us but most of
us remember the last assault weapons ban
expired in 2004 there were challenges to
that at that time how different would an
assault weapons ban or any Congressional
gun law be in in the context of these
recent Supreme Court decisions including
maybe even Heller which is more than a
decade old now
like a piece of wood and a buzz saw I
mean that's kind of what they have set
up for themselves in terms of the
constitutionality of any law with
respect to the Second Amendment and let
me just be clear when the Supreme Court
decided the Bruin opinion
it was not setting a standard of
judicial review right and when I say
that what I mean is the lens pursuant to
which every Court in the country has to
review a law before the Bruin decision
our laws around the Second Amendment
would be reviewed with a balancing test
what's the interest of Public Safety let
me counter that by understanding the
origins of the Second Amendment and does
this infringe the Second Amendment that
was the standard of review
for 200 years up until the Bruin
decision right and the Brewing decision
said no no no no no no we have to look
at this three prongs test and the one
that is really challenging is is there a
historical corollary to this law in
colonial times and that will be right up
front for Roberts to consider
in this next session and I don't envy
that task I think it's a tough one but I
hope that they reframe this because it's
the only amendment to the Constitution
that we actually have this test for
finally Chris the bipartisan safer
communities Act Right signed last summer
by the president it allotted more money
among other things for mental health
programs the parents in this particular
case of the Nashville shooter told
police that she'd been under mental
health care for an emotional disorder
they had her sell her weapons but she
clearly hid some I wonder if this points
out the cracks that rules can fall
through you know should these parents
have called law enforcement or files an
order with a court honestly it just
breaks my heart as a mother of a 21 year
old and 19 year old
these parents were in a tough position
and the reason why is because Tennessee
has not passed an extreme risk
Protection Law you reference the
bipartisan safer communities act that's
the federal law that incented states hey
Tennessee we will give you free money to
implement this law to make sure that
parents with kids who are at risk that
they are able to take action and remove
guns and put these individuals in the
background check system that's how that
law Works Tennessee does not have that
law and unfortunately based on our
current system I would say there's
almost nothing available to these
parents to meaningfully remove guns from
their 28 year old daughter Chris Brown
president of United against gun violence
at the Brady Center thank you so much
for joining us thank you so much thanks
for having me
thank you
and in other news I'm Gianna jalosi
residents of Greenland spring forward
for the last time while the U.S and
Europe debate about whether to stick to
the twice yearly clock switching
Greenland's Parliament voted to stick to
Daylight Saving Time year round
officials say it's going to give
greenlanders another hour of daylight in
the afternoons more time to do business
with Europe and the rest of the world
and quote an opportunity to slow down in
a fast-paced world geographically
sparsely populated Greenland belongs to
the North American continent but
geopolitically it's in Europe earlier
this month a bipartisan group of U.S
senators reintroduced legislation to
make Daylight Saving Time permanent here
in the U.S after it unanimously passed
the upper chamber last year but failed
to get a vote in the house because
lawmakers couldn't agree on whether to
keep Standard time or permanent daylight
saving time since 2015 about 30 states
have introduced legislation to end the
twice yearly changing of the clocks for
the Fox News rundown I'm Gianna jalosi
thank you
[Music]
new from the Fox News podcasts Network
I'm Dana Perino join me for season three
of my limited time podcast everything
will be okay based on my best-selling
book of the same name make sure you
subscribe to this series wherever you
download podcasts and leave a rating and
review subscribe to this podcast at
foxnewspodcasts.com it's time for your
Fox News commentary will Kane what's on
your mind there is so much to discuss
when once again some deviant deranged
individual steps inside of a school and
kills America's children Audrey Hale did
so at the Covenant Christian school in
Nashville Tennessee killing three
children and three adults and we can
have plenty of conversations around the
cultural movement of this person but for
today I want to celebrate some real men
the Nashville Tennessee Police
Department covered itself in glory
in the wake of this tragedy if you
haven't go wherever you need to go watch
it the body cam footage from officers
like Rex Engelbert and Michael Collazo
these officers arrived on the scene and
within four minutes had taken down
Audrey Hale you can watch as Engelbert
competently confidently goes room to
room hallway to hallway clearing that
building you'll be reminded of
leadership real leadership when you
listen to Collazo calmly tell his
teammates go go go lead with your rifle
I'm with you to the right keep pushing
throughout the three minutes it takes
these men to arrive at the second floor
no hesitation going through any door no
pause coming around any corner until
Engelbert is the first to go around that
last corner and take down Audrey Hale it
is an amazing Testament to the values of
real men
if you want to hear more check out the
will Kane podcast on Fox News podcast
download rate and review wherever you
get your audio entertainment
you've been listening to the Fox News
rundown now and now stay up to date by
subscribing to this podcast at
foxnewspodcasts.com listen ad free on
FOX News podcasts Plus on Apple podcast
and Prime members can listen to the show
ad free on Amazon music and for up to
the minute news go to foxnews.com
pull up a chair and join me Rachel
Campos Tuffy and me former US
Congressman Sean Duffy as we share our
perspective on the discussions happening
at kitchen tables Across America
download from the kitchen table the
Duffy spent fox newspodcast.com or
wherever you download podcasts
love Fox News click the Subscribe button
to get more of the news and opinion you
trust and click the Fox News rundown
playlist for the latest episodes